there's a battle going on in america's
skies right now over the future of
spirit airlines see on one side fellow
ultra low cost carrier frontier airlines
is trying to merge with spirit and on
the other slightly higher budget jetblue
is attempting a hostile takeover of
spirit now this battle has the potential
to reshape america's aviation sector so
to win both sides have been locked in a
war of words as they try and convince
spirit and its shareholders that they'd
be a better match than their rival so
how did we get here why is spirit so
coveted and what could this mean for
passengers let's dive in
[Music]
okay so here's how we got here after a
deal had been rumored for years in early
february of 2022 frontier offered to buy
spirit for 2.9 billion dollars in cash
and stock the deal was set to close by
the end of this year but then in comes
jet blue with a rival unsolicited offer
so they come in with a 3.6 billion
dollar offer i'll cash that's wsj's
alison cider who has been following this
battle closely now spirit has a little
bit of a dilemma they have you know this
partner that they've been talking to for
months and months and they're excited
about the deal and now jetblue is
offering you know what at least jeff
blue describes as an offer that's too
good to refuse despite it being higher
spirit rejects jetblue's offer over
worries around antitrust concerns and
jetblue obviously was unhappy with that
so jetblue begins a hostile takeover
attempt by appealing to spirit
shareholders offering to buy their
shares for 30 each and encouraging them
to vote against the frontier deal
basically saying you know spirit
shareholders this will send a message to
spirits board and management that you
really don't want to do this frontier
deal that this jet blue deal is much
better for you so it's sort of a long
saga but that's where we are
so why is there such an intense battle
over a no frills airline well whoever
takes spirit would become the fifth
biggest airline in america in terms of
seat capacity and both jetblue and
frontier have said that would put them
in a better position to take on the big
four of delta united south west and
american airlines they just think spirit
is sort of like a once in a lifetime
opportunity to grow more quickly than
they can grow on their own now frontier
has a similar business model and similar
planes to spirit but they mainly operate
on different sides of america they're
arguing sort of that they're putting
these networks together it's really
going to make them a national presence
and for jetblue taking spirit could help
them avoid pilot shortages and backlogs
for new plane orders it's going to take
spirits big yellow planes with the seats
all smushed really close together it's
gonna rip out some rows make a little
more legroom you know retrofit them so
they look just like jetblue planes but
there could be another reason why these
two companies so desperately want spirit
and that's to stop the other side from
getting it some analysts have suggested
like if spirit and frontier merge
suddenly they're the fifth largest
carrier blue's getting bumps lower on
the list maybe that leaves them a little
vulnerable what do they do next so what
could a potential deal mean for you the
passenger well it could affect ticket
prices root choices and seat
availability here's how first off ticket
prices now jetblue and frontier both
argue that the presence of a bigger
low-cost carrier would force the big
four to have to lower their ticket
prices and expand their own economy
offerings to remain competitive but a
deal would also mean there's one less
budget carrier operating in america and
less choice often means higher prices
next is roots because to avoid falling
foul of anti-trust regulators jetblue
and frontier could have to sacrifice
some airport slots gates and routes
jetblue has said like they preemptively
agreed to make these divestments in new
york and boston frontier hasn't
discussed that you know in such detail
but the justice department could ask
either carrier to make those kinds of
cuts finally there's the number of seats
because if jetblue wins the battle for
spirit it's likely it will reconfigure
its planes by removing some seats to
create extra legroom and that could mean
less seat availability so what's going
to happen next well spirit shareholders
will vote on the frontier deal on june
10th and it's likely that jetblue will
be hoping to get a bit more of an
indication of which way those
shareholders are leaning before then so
stay tuned there may be more turbulence
ahead